[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
ein leckeres rezept für bedeckt mit
schafkäse und das geht super schnell
weil wir dafür fertigen ewv cup benutzen
und wir brauchen auch gar nicht so viele
zutaten wie mich ein kilogramm schafkäse
eurer wahl weiche butter kompletten für
die form 200 milliliter ron bloom öl 100
gramm flüchtige geschmolzene butter 200
milliliter milch und außerdem benötigen
sind auch drei pakete joker blätter ihr
500 gramm
die findet in jedem türkischen
supermarkt das ist einfach sehr dünnes
fladenbrot und ich zeige euch nochmal
hier diese aussehen nimmt auf jeden fall
drei pakete nur dann kommt ihr damit dem
ganzen welt auf und die lüfterblätter
die sind sehr trocken und deswegen mache
ich mir hier eine mischung fertig gebe
dafür man eigentlich schiffe und rührt
abgeklärt und gibt dann noch die
flüchtigen food haben dazu ein
sonnenblumenöl flüssige butter und milch
anschließend nehme ich mir mein tiefes
backblech und hätte das großzügig mit
butter 1
jetzt nehme ich mir schon mal eine
packung djk blätter und falte sie
auseinander
[Musik]
in 90 prozent der fälle wird euch die
jungpartei greifen dass es überhaupt
kein problem ist eigentlich gar nicht zu
vermeiden denn der teig ist sehr trocken
und klebt ziemlich gut aneinander
in newsweek dann einfach auf die
arbeitsfläche legen ein bisschen
zusammenpuzzeln
und dann großzügig mit der mischung zu
streichen und hierbei wird die nicht zu
sparsam sein denn die gekauften
newsletter die winzige sehr trocken zu
beginnen und durch diese mischung aus öl
butter und milch wird es einfach viel
weicher anschließend gibt ihr da
großzügig von eurem schafskäse drauf und
wer möchte der kann dann noch gerne
gehackte petersilie hinzufügen ich hatte
leider kandidaten er das nicht so gerne
macht und habe das tier einfach
weggelassen
das ganze wird dann nacheinander einmal
nach innen und dann wieder nach außen
geklappt am ende wie das ganze aus wie
ein langer breiter fächer und dass der
joker tage risse an der stelle das macht
überhaupt gar nicht das kann man einfach
ganz normal mit hydranten und am ende
merkt das niemand
das kommt jetzt auf das backblech und
mit den restlichen juka bett haben
einfach so weiter verfahren bis das
blech voll ist
[Musik]
jetzt schneide ich noch mit einem
scharfen messer die abstehenden ränder
ab und gebe dann im rest von der
buttermilch mischung damit er auch nicht
verschwendet wird
da kommt jetzt noch eine ordentliche
menge größte der welt
und dann kommt das auch schon bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze für 30 minuten
in den ofen
und das ist das leckere endergebnis
unten der würzige weiße schafe und oben
drüber dann die knusprige joker decke
mit reza ich zeige euch auch definitiv
mal wie ihr yoga teig selber herstellen
könnt aber das ist die variante für
schnell besuch für leute die wenig zeit
haben oder für leute die einfach mal
ganz schnell was leckeres möchten
falls euch das video gefallen hat dann
hörst mir gern ein auge oder damit ihr
auch kein video mehr verpasst bis zum
nächsten mal auf die skizzen